see this is when I believe in plastic
surgery because people be like God gave
you that you should be beautiful but
then I'm like but sometimes people are
not given the gifts of beauty bro if
those is that are bigger than my eyes
and then my ears are super small my lips
are like non-existent I look like a gray
alien I look like this can someone
really looks like that that's offensive
he did no cheekbones it's just too
droopy saggy cheeks like boobs yeah what
if Joe and in someone's like you're
beautiful just the way you are and I'm
like you because you will not have
sex with me I am not beautiful you're
not throw me none everyone's like you
should accept the way that you are cause
God created you that way and I'm like
if I could pay 20K and I get these
saggy cheeks lift it up give me some new
ears luscious lips what do you do about
the eyes though the really small eyes
I didn't know I had small eyes
look your nose did you say you have
small no I had a yeah